sometimes the role of the starchitect
can take away from the art there have
been certain institutions where the
architecture was criticized for not
giving a space where the art can really
stand on its own this dates back to the
guggenheim Frank Lloyd Wright was
criticized for that and in fact in the
Guggenheim there's some work that's very
hard to show some work like sculpture
you're going to show some david smith
sculptures there they look fabulous
paintings are very hard to show in the
Guggenheim the other thing that happened
with some of the starchitect sure is
that the costs I mean there were some
notorious cases that was the case with
the museum the collar trava Museum in
Milwaukee where it cost more than was
anticipated and the museum was perceived
as not having left aside enough funds to
do programming to make exhibitions to
make acquisitions that kind of thing and
we've seen that in a number of
institutions now because of course it's
so much more easy to get funding to get
donations from individuals corporations
everyone for these fabulous editions but
nobody wants to pay to fix the roof